I said, welcome Dr Starkey. Thank you. Uh,
I know that we want to get to the point
of talking about how these things are
going to kill all of us and we're all
doomed. Uh, but before we do that,
before we get started about that,
we should,
we should talk a little about about what
these things are that are going to kill
us all. Um, so, uh, your, your book
of course is a, a nonfiction book,
but I couldn't help thinking while
reading it, that if it were a novel,
the main characters in it
would be comets and asteroids.
So maybe we should start there.
Talk about a little bit about what
comets and asteroids are and how they are
different from each other.
Sure. Okay. So, um, I guess there's a lot
of misunderstanding now about what the,
what the differences between
comments and asteroids. Um,
so classically we had this idea that
comments forms and the very cold outer
reaches of the solar system.
So when our son first formed,
it was surrounded by this cloud of gas
and dust and ice and way out in the outer
reaches of the solar system. We pass
where any of the planets are today. Um,
we formed the comments and
they're literally just like,
as I describe it as like
a scoop of this cloud,
he'd basically just take this gas and
dust and ice and kind of bind it together
a little bit, but they're not
very well like held together.
They're not very well consolidated.
So they're almost like a snowball
essentially with a lot of Dustin. Um,
but what why they're so important
is that they're exceptionally old.
So there was old as the sun,
4.6 billion years old,
which means they can tell us a
lot about where we came from,
where everything in our
solar system came from.
Right.
Did they sort of primitive object.
Exactly. Um, whereas the
asteroids are at hand,
they're also very old with saying
probably nearly 4.6 if not four,
paid for just about 4.5 billion years old.
And we can think of those as kind of
the leftover building rubble from making
the planet. So they formed in the inner
solar system much closer to the sun,
just as the rocky planets did like us
and then mercury, Venus and Mars. Um,
and it was just those bits and pieces
of planet that didn't get made into a
planet. They just got left out. And then
they collected, um, in the asteroid belt,
which is now between Mars and Jupiter.
Um,
so the asteroids are really important
because they preserve this history of
planet building, which is really hard to
look at because if we just take earth,
we've had all sorts of evolution on
earth since it formed and we have plate
tectonics as most people know.
So especially living in La,
you probably know too well that was an
earthquake last night actually, that,
you know,
our plates are moving and we create
earthquakes and volcanoes and this changes
the surface of our planet. So if we
want to go back to the beginning of us,
we want to see what it was made from
and how it started out and how life got
here and how our water got here.
It's really hard to do.
It's really hard to
pick apart that history.
So asteroids are really important in
that sense. They can kind of allow us to,
to glimpse back at that time because they
didn't really evolve since the forms,
not a whole lot anyway.
They sort of preserve those conditions.
So that's the classic view.
I think we're going to come onto in a
bit kind of how that view is maybe not so
accurate now. It's not
wholly wrong, but, um,
but we've kind of updated
our view about these objects,
but we should remember that
that's the classical distinction.
And I love that that image
of the asteroids is kind
of the leftover legos from
the solar system.
You snap the whole bunch of
things together into planets
and these are the ones
that are kind of scattered on the floor.
Yep.
That's right. Yeah. Yeah. And, um,
and so because these might might
come into the picture as well,
can we talk a little about what, uh, uh,
meteors and meteorites and meteoroids are?
Yeah. So, okay. That there's a
lot of confusion about that. So I,
me to write is literally just a piece
of rock from space on another planet.
So on earth we can go and collect me,
tried sitting on the ground.
And it could be a piece of a planet,
it could be a piece of a
comment or an asteroid.
And what happens is that collisions
happening happen in space and they've
happened for Millennia and little pieces
of rocks will get knocked off planets.
If another is an asteroid
collides with them.
And some of this asteroid might end
up just floating about in space,
but little pieces of it.
So it's a meteoroid and space.
And then when it comes
through the atmosphere, it's
becomes a mature. So you got,
we had the meteor shower recently that
you can see little pieces coming through
often that stuff.
So when we get a big fireball,
these beautiful scenes that we get, that's
a larger piece of rock coming through.
If that rock makes it to the surface,
if it doesn't explode in the atmosphere
and completely disintegrate a piece of
rock on the surface as the meats,
right?
So the great thing about them
is that we can collect them.
Sometimes we can actually see them
forward. If you see a fire ball,
you can sometimes trace it and then find
that fresh rock literally just straight
from space and you can solve it.
Or we get older falls where you know,
there's a court fines where we've kind of,
they felt while ago,
it could be millions of years ago. Um,
and we can then go and sample them.
And it's great because it means we can
get samples from space because we don't
actually go into space very often. Like
we going to space a bit. And when we do,
we often don't collect samples because
if we want to go out and collect samples
and spaces, almost like two
missions. Do you want to like this?
The why we haven't sampled Mars.
And people find that quite surprising
when I say we don't have any samples from
Mars. We've been there a whole lot.
There's loads of instruments on Mars,
but we haven't brought back any, any
rocks from there because yeah, right.
So we need to, we will be, we
will be doing it in the future.
Right now at the moment, the only
rocks we have from Mars Mitch Rights.
So that's the only way we can sample them.
They're free samples, which is great.
Right? But we don't know
exactly where they came from.
So if we send a mission there,
we consomme politically is that clean
a particular base and that we're
interested in and then
we can bring that back.
But that's basically a
second mission to launch,
relaunch off another planet or
an asteroid or a comment. It's,
it's really complicated. So that's
why we haven't done it very often.
Obviously we have a lot of samples from
the moon, thank goodness. So that's right.
Yeah, we've done it a bit,
but we need to do it more.
But we have meet traits in the meantime,
which can really help us out. Right.
Okay. So the, so the asteroids all live,
well not all live but mainly
collected in the asteroid belt,
which is this region between the
orbits of Mars and Jupiter. Yup. Um,
and they're the asteroid belt,
uh,
I learned from your book isn't
really all one thing, right?
There's like an inner and an outer belt
and there was a distinction between
those two regions.
You to talk about that.
Yes. So when we studied
asteroids and asteroid belt,
we kind of initially thought they
were all going to be the same,
just these kind of rocky objects
that look a bit like, you know,
failed planets and,
and the small and they're all very small.
There are a couple of large objects that,
but actually when we look in
detail from the inner belt,
which is going to be the
bit that's closer to Mars,
I'm sure enough these things do
look like asteroids. In fact,
some of them are made
completely of metals.
So if you take the core of
earth that is made of metal,
we'll probably aware of that.
But actually we can sample a sort of
core from a planet if we sample some of
these asteroids and there's a Nasa mission
actually going, um, in the twenties,
twenties called psyche and it's going
to be going to look at one of these
objects so we can sample those.
And they're very much like we
consider the classical asteroids.
But as we move out to the outer
belts on that kind of Jupiter side,
what we find is that they change
and they actually become IC.
Some of these objects and they have
a lot of carbonaceous materials.
So what I'm saying here is that we,
we've got organic matter
now that's not uncommon.
We have organic matter in most of the
asteroids apart from the ones that are
really made of just a
metal. Um, this isn't life.
People get very excited when we
see organic methods. It's not life.
It's literally just carbon,
hydrogen bonding and some oxygen and it's,
it's organic matter that is
potentially the precursor for life.
So it's really exciting.
These objects contain a lot of organic
matter because we still don't understand
how life got to earth.
Um,
we're obviously the only planet
we know of that contains life. Um,
we don't know how I got here and it's
kind of just, it's ridiculous, right?
I always find it quite funny that we
still don't know how we are here and we're
like these very intelligent beings that
can do all sorts of amazing things.
But how we got her as a mystery. So
we want to study these objects, um,
to try and understand if they
could have delivered life.
So these asteroids on the outer belt,
they also contain ice.
So they look very much like the comments
that I described at the beginning.
And actually this is where this kind
of distinction between the two objects
breaks down a little bit because these
actually might be comments when they
formed. The idea is that some
of them really could have
formed in the outer solar
system.
And then there was a huge reorganization
of the solar system after the large
planets formed.
And some of these comments kind of got
thrown into the inner solar system and
got trapped in the asteroid belt.
So we actually find that they're kind
of comments, but they are asteroids.
So it's kind of confusing in that respect.
But the same happen the other way.
Some of the asteroids that formed near
the Sun got ejected out of the solar
system.
Some of them probably disappeared from
our solar system completely and others
ended up in one of their homes of
where the comments live now. Um,
so there's probably almost certainly
some objects in what we call the Co,
the quip about where Pluto lives,
which probably asteroidal in origin,
but now they're sitting somewhere
very cold. So there is a bill.
This is where kind of the
overlap starts to happen, right,
because the cell systems kind of crazy.
I love that image from your book of of
Jupiter sort of throwing a tantrum and
rampaging around the solar system and
kind of throwing stuff all over the place
and kind of mixing it all up
so it's not in range, you know,
and this kind of neat, tidy little
categories that we thought at first.
I think that's the thing.
We had this beautiful fee because of the
solar system is very hard to understand.
Obviously we need to visit it to
understand it. And we haven't been too,
I mean we've been to a lot of it,
but we still don't know how all the
planets formed. And Jupiter is enormous.
Like it's,
it really controls our solar system
and it's gravity if it decides to move
around, which he did in the past, um,
can just really cause havoc throughout,
you know,
it can just not planets around and,
and particularly smaller objects
like asteroids. Um, so that is,
that period of our solar system
history is very, very crazy. Sorry.
Yeah, you talked about it yet. Swapping
the orbits of Uranus and Neptune.
So Neptune is further out
currently and Uranus is closer in,
but they were the other way around.
This is what we think.
Yeah. And these are massive planets, you
know, and, and they have huge gravity.
So it's kind of crazy thing. And
obviously it's not going to happen now,
but what we can do now is look out to
other solar systems around other planets,
planetary systems,
around other stars.
And we can kind of look at what
is happening now. So I love that.
This is not my field,
but this is astronomy and it's absolutely
fascinating that we can look out and
see,
we can kind of see our solar system as
it was billions of years ago because we
can look at other stars and see actually
planets forming at this very time,
what kind of,
what's happening here.
So this is another way we can try and
figure out what happened 4.6 billion years
ago and afterwards.
So it's fascinating.
Right on. Um, so, so in much the
same way that the, there's a,
there's these kind of two
regions of the asteroid belt.
There's kind of two regions of the,
where the comments live as well.
You talked about the Kuyper belt,
which is the near region and there's
also the Oort cloud because the farther
region you want to talk
about the distinction between
those two regions as well.
Yeah. How far away they are. Yes.
It's kind of crazy. Um, so this
sentence is in space always.
I think everyone just goes,
oh yeah, it's pretty far.
It's like really far to Jupiter and Pluto.
We know he went to Pluto with the
new horizons mission recently,
and it's still going through
the quip about, so you know,
a couple of years later,
I think it was 2015 it met three times.
Um,
and it's still going
through the for bouts.
So it is 25 times wider
than the asteroid belt.
And the asteroid belt is
already fairly large. Right.
And it's just in terms of distances,
it's not that far.
So it's just past Neptune Uranus.
It's kind of just on the
edge of the solar system.
But these objects that are
there that I see that dusty,
the kind of mostly fairly small
and we can see most of them,
so we kind of know roughly what is there,
but they're sort of bound
to our son by the gravity.
They're not too far that they're
not kind of bound west the system.
But once you get to the edge of the quote
about it sort of becomes no man's land.
Um, we have a region called
the stack scattered desk,
which is just some random objects,
which are probably mostly cometary. Um,
and they're kind of on crazy orbits a
little bit and we don't understand them a
whole lot, but they are, we can't
see all of them, but they're kind of,
we know that they're there.
But then we get to this theoretical
phase of the solar system,
which is the Oort cloud.
Um,
and I was fascinated to learn
what I did a few years ago,
that the Oort cloud is not
proven like theoretical.
And we always talk about all Clark
comments and new day we have what we call
long period comments,
which are these comments that come into
the inner solar system and orbit the sun.
Um, and they have to have more
bits of more than 200 years.
So the way we know that awkward is there,
partly because we have to balance out
the mass of the solar system somehow.
So we kind of, you know, know guests
there had to be something out there,
but then we get these
comments coming in at it,
really round random angles into that.
So basically I should probably just
sidestep a little bit. The solar system,
as most people know, all the planets on
the same plane. And so as a quick about,
so we're sort of all going
around the sun and nicely,
Pluto's doing something slightly
different and then we move out to the Oort
cloud. And this is literally a cloud
around the whole sun. So what happens is,
is one, one of these comments decides
to come into the inner solar system.
They can come in from all random angles.
They're not going to be
coming along with that plane.
So that's how we sort of know this cloud
is there because these are the little
visitors from the outer solar system
come in and, and we can spot them,
but we can't directly see them if they're
there because they're just too far.
Right. You know, these objects
are tiny and they're too far away.
So this is partly why until
new horizons got to Pluto,
we didn't really know much about it.
Like we just could not
really see it in any detail.
So I'm really excited to see the next
object is going to in the queef about, um,
and then the Oort cloud.
We just, I don't, you know,
we're never going to get there in anyone's
lifetime. It's just the spaceships.
We'll continue going,
but we are not going to know.
They will run out of battery by
then anyway, so, right. Yeah.
Doing the math on the numbers from your
book. I got that light leaves the sun,
it gets to the near edge of the
Kuyper belt in four hours. Okay.
So that's the Kuiper belt.
It gets to the near edge of the Oort
cloud and something like nine and a half
months. Okay. That's the,
that's the magnitude of the
difference that we're talking.
Yep. And then the Oort cloud, it would
take another t as the cross, right?
Yeah, exactly right. Yeah. It's like
from one to three light years distance.
Yeah.
Can just space cost speeds. I mean, this
is going to take, um, hundreds of pounds,
tens of thousands of
years, I'm guessing. Yes.
Right. It's somewhere 40,000
years or something. Something
along those lines. Yeah.
Sorry. It's the very far right.
And actually had a reasonable labs,
objects of batty bound to our son.
They are actually influenced often by in
the galaxy, the passing of other stars,
like they can be knocked out
of the orbit, um, by, you know,
the literally other stars nearby
because the almost closer to other solar
systems or stars then.
Right.
Those are the things I was fascinated
when, just a little factoid,
I was fascinated by from
your book that that the,
the outer edge of the Oort cloud,
which is around our son is actually
closer to the next star yeah.
Than it is to our son.
But they are literally within
our sales system. So it's, yeah,
it's kind of where you define the
edge of the solar system and there are
different definitions for where it is,
right. When you enter interstellar space,
which is the bit in between the stars.
Um, and so yeah, the voyager missions,
which settled in the 1970s they
are now in interstellar space,
but that just means they are past
the cliff about, right, right. Yeah.
Yeah. As long as you're talking about
like awesome little facts from your book.
Um, the, the, at this, this is the
thing that that kind of blew my mind.
The asteroid belt,
all the asteroids from the asteroid belt
put together would have less mass than
Earth's moon. Yeah. Yeah. Which is very
different from your picture of it is,
you know,
you think of the Millennium Falcon
swimming through the asteroid belt in the
asteroids are all kind of like
huge and close together and yeah,
but it's really kind
of Nice guy. Hey, quiet
Scott's it out.
And that's a good thing.
Otherwise they would collide more often
and we should have more issues in the
inner solar system with
potentially being hit by one.
So actually it's a good thing that,
that nicely far apart so you
can get through quite easily.
You can find a good route.
Well, well that's a, that's a nice
little transition for us. Um, uh,
so now that we know that we have a handle
on kind of what all the players are,
then comets and asteroids in the solar
system and the media is of course,
once they get here, um, let's talk about
how they're going to kill us. All. Great.
Yeah. So, so one of the things that
you talked about in the book is,
is you kind of point out that
comets and asteroids give us,
but they also take it the way that they
might have brought life to earth. Um,
but they also, you know, wiped out the
dinosaurs and could do the same to us. Um,
I'm,
I'm a little hesitant to ascribe a
properties like good and evil to inanimate
objects like that. Maybe we should
talk about them and helpful or scary,
but how do you think about them?
Do you think that there are things
that should be revered or feared or
so,
I mean,
it was probably no surprise as somebody
who's researched these objects quite a
while that I revere them.
Because one of the things about it is yes,
they do have the potential
to collide with us.
And we think we see for about a
hundred years. So probably all of us,
unless you know how to live a
lot longer than a hundred years,
then you're going to be okay.
But the thing is like our descendants
going to be okay and the more we can learn
about the subjects now,
the better prepared we are to do
something about one of them hitting us.
So if we don't understand our enemy,
then we don't know how to fight it.
So I love these objects because they can
tell us a lot about where we came from,
about our past and how everything
started in the solar system. But yeah,
they do really have the
potential to cause havoc.
Got a large asteroid could hit
us, um, pass that a hundred years.
I mean there's a chance one could
hit us within a hundred years,
but it's very unlikely pass that
we at the moment don't know.
It's a kind of a continuously updated
list of potentially hazardous asteroids
and comets,
which you know,
astronomy's or studying and they need
to understand better how they move in on
that orbits and what you know,
the next orbit of the sun is going to
do and if they're going to be altered by
passing Jupiter in the
future or something.
So we need to understand exactly what
they're doing, how they're spinning,
and then we need to know what they're
made of because if we don't know what
they're made of,
well some ideas like Armageddon,
if you've seen the Hollywood movie right,
they actually go and detonate
some explosive inside the
asteroid to blow it up.
Well,
it depends what you're dealing with.
If this asteroid has made a
pure metal that might not work,
you might not even be able to
drill into the thing too to put an,
to put some exclusive with inside it.
But if we talk about a comment well made,
if it's coming towards earth, it might
just explode on atmospheric entry anyway.
So it's kind of like,
okay,
we need to know what we're dealing with
if we want to go and deflect or destroy
one before it gets here.
Right. And you talked about this
some in the book that that, uh,
even even blowing up the asteroid might
not be good because now you have a whole
bunch of asteroids that are going to
kill you instead of one big Astoria.
Exactly.
And I think one of the things is like the,
the more advanced notice we get,
the better.
So if we can see that an object
is heading for us and it's large,
say a kilometer or so,
um, and it's 10 years out,
then we have time to launch a mission.
This is why we need to do a bit of work
in advance because of course it's not
that easy to launch a mission
just straight the next day.
So we did a few years to figure out
how to launch the mission there.
It'd be great if we had one ready to
go for any of these objects. So sure.
What we're currently working on
in planetary defense. Um, it's a,
it's a big topic at the moment and
research and governments are actually
interested in this,
which is great because we need them to be,
to support the research community launch
mission. Basically, the longer you have,
the better. If you want to deflect
something and it's way off,
it's going to be a smaller
nudge to deflect it.
If you just want to push it out the way,
then if it's right next to earth already,
you're going to have to deflect a
long way for, it's a mess. Ideally,
we'd want it to deflect them. We just
want to put it on a different course.
And this is our planet and we don't
care if it hits another planet,
but we want to protect our
own planet. Um, we could,
if we're stuck and we
don't have much notice,
we could explode it in some way
if we can find a way. Of course,
he might need to use nuclear weapons,
which is not going to be fun if you're
going to get the reign of this nuclear
weapon falling down on the planet.
But
possibly in violation of treaties?
I think if we, yeah, I think so.
I think Nico weapons aren't allowed to
be used in spaces like in a bad way.
So I think everyone was saving our planet
then we'd probably let it go and maybe
some nuclear fallout wouldn't be as
bad as just being hit by an asteroid.
So we'd, we might allow
it, but you know it,
it sounds like science fiction
and it is science fiction,
but it's also now turning into reality.
These are really kind of
what we're thinking of.
If there's other crazier ideas that
we don't have to explain these things,
there's other ideas that we can
spray paint one side of this object.
So generally these objects are very dark
and as they go by it, something else,
heat it up. Now if you can
change one side of the asteroid,
if you could spray paint
it white or metallic,
it's going to heat up differently as it
goes near to the sun and it will start
spinning differently.
And if it spins differently,
it'll change is all bit gradually.
So these are very gentle techniques.
It sounds a bit mad trying
to spray paint in space,
but this is literally one of one of
the things we could do or cover it with
something to kind of change.
It's how it reacts to the Sun's heat.
I never saw the movie Armageddon, but I,
I, I gathered what it's about. Is it yet?
I haven't seen it.
I gather what it's about is they
sent like basically miners to space
Ben AFLAC where you split us
up there, right. Oil minus.
Yeah. They would drill it,
but so it, it never occurred to
me like I, I kind of get that,
but it had never occurred to me that
maybe what you won't want to sentence
taggers that could yellow spray paint
the side, right? Yeah, they would,
they would put a nice mural on the side.
It would look pretty as it
passed us by safely. I mean,
every hour to work on that. That's
your next book. Should do that.
I can be the novel. Right? Yeah. Um,
but yeah, I mean, of course we're
not actually going to send people up.
In reality what's going to happen is that
we use robots and in space, of course,
all the time we use robots just
because they're more expendable.
We don't really care if
we killed the robots.
We care because they cost a lot and a
lot of people's careers going into making
them something else. The legs really fall,
fall in love with it. Yeah. Don't we all,
but yeah,
it's not human.
So there's this big issues of
sending humans into space and yeah,
if we're going to send them
to landing on an asteroid,
well asteroids don't have an awful lot
of gravity cause they're small objects,
so they're going to have to be tethered
on, um, uh, can't remember what they did.
And I'm forgetting if, if
they would, I think it was
just roaming about freely. Um,
they would probably a float
off into space, you know,
so it's not easy to send
humans to these objects.
I'm sure it will happen in the
future way into the future.
But for now it will be robots, which
again is not easy because as you know,
you're trying to run a,
a robot from earth and millions
of miles away has its issues.
Communication Times a tricky cause. It
takes a long time to communicate, right?
Things go wrong.
Like I run a lab instrument for many years
and I could be in that tinkering with
it and something went wrong.
I could change things,
but if that instrument is way off on an
asteroid, there's nothing you can do.
If it breaks, there's not ran off like you
can do. So yeah, there's lots of issues.
So, but we have actually sent a
space missions to these objects to,
to comets and asteroids before.
And uh, it was, it was, uh, uh,
I would say it was,
it was pretty evident from reading your
book that you're a big fan of both the
startups and Rosetta missions.
I am, yeah. They got a chat to me.
Speaking of, speaking of landing something
on a, on a, uh, one of those objects,
Rosetta actually did that. Yeah. Tell us
a little bit about those missions. Yes.
Sorry. I mean, the NASA
stardust mission was like,
it had happened at head to board at SOM,
pulls back as I was starting my career
in this and this area of science. Um,
so the NASA status was
really groundbreaking.
It was actually quite a cheap mission
and it flew to comment built to,
and it wanted to bring a sample back,
but it didn't have enough money to land
on this subject and come back from it.
So they flew through the
tail of the comments.
So I had mentioned that comments
have a lot of ice and dust in them,
and as they go by the sun, this
material gets heated up. So sure enough,
the ice streams off the
comment takes dust with it.
And that's what the thesis of the tail,
when you get the famous
comments that you see,
all the beautiful images of that tale of
material is literally the gas and dust
coming off of that comment.
Um,
and so what they did was just flew
through the tail of this comment and
literally just got impacting
particles on this collector.
And that was their comment samples and
they closed up that it'll collector and
jettison it back to earth and the
rest of space cock carried on.
And we had these samples back in 2006.
Um,
and they will often ask sample it real
samples of a comment because it's hard to
know if we've got any niche rights of
comments because as I said earlier,
they probably explode as they enter
the atmosphere. So it's hard to know.
We've definitely got one on earth.
Um,
so this was a real groundbreaking mission
and then it also really turn the books
on what,
how we thought comments formed and what
it showed us was that actually this,
we know it's a comment,
it behaves like a comment.
We know it's all bad that it comes from
um, you know, from the Kuiper belt.
And then what we find is that actually
it doesn't look like a comment when we
look at the rocks within it,
right? They look like an asteroid.
So it doesn't sound very exciting
to be like, hold on a minute.
This thing formed way out in
the outer solar system yet.
It's got components within it that
look exactly like the planets that look
exactly like the building blocks of the
planets that form very close to the sun.
So how do we get ice and hot
material contained within one object?
So this was why everything got blown
apart at this stage. And the scientists,
you know,
and they're still working on it.
We're still trying to understand how we
get hot material from the inner solar
system out to the comet forming region,
um,
to form a comment that then is covered
in ice and dust and all the normal stuff
of the we it to contain. Um, and, and
there's lots of different theories,
but that is still an ongoing
area that we need to understand.
So we know that the story is not as simple
as it could be as we'd like it to be,
as,
as the textbooks would have us believe
before we move on to said it,
start us to also brought us back
in addition to bring us back.
The first sample from a comment
brought us back samples of interstellar
protocols, right? It did. Yeah.
The detector around the other way.
And exactly what a few of those as well.
Yeah. Basically we have particles
from interstellar space,
which is the space around all the
stars and the solar system. Um,
and these particles are traveling
sexually fast. Um, and they,
we haven't really been up to sample
them before, but so this, um, kind of,
it was called like a tennis
racket style collector.
We kind of just came up out
of the spacecraft once I
collect a comment particles
and then the backside collected
interstellar particles and they're tiny.
They're like the best so tiny that we
can't like the Colette particles or small,
I'm saying like probably a maximum of
like the width of a human hair would be
the largest particles we
collected if that. Um,
the interstellar particles are
10 times smaller than that.
So they're very hard to
see on the collector and
they're very hard to analyze.
But like there wasn't a
whole instrument built, um,
somewhere in la or somewhere
in California. Can't remember
which, uh, university,
it's that, but they basically made a
whole instruments to measure these, these,
these particles because we can sample
then our galaxy because we have no other
way. We haven't been able
to go out to our galaxy,
but these particles come to us so we can
actually start to understand what our
galaxy looks like and what it's made of,
which is fascinating. So yeah, it was,
you know, just did so much that
mission. It was fascinating.
There were, there were some other
really interesting things in there. You,
you go into it a lot of detail
about exactly how the, the,
we're able to get some of those,
those samples out and so on. But um,
we might want to come back to that.
But I did want to also give you a chance
to talk about Rosetta as well. Yeah.
Fascinating.
Such a great mission.
So I was just really
well placed on the sound.
We're really lucky to be where I was
working when there was that commission.
Little is ongoing now.
I have to say I wasn't in it from the
beginning cause it took 20 years to plan
this mission. In fact, I think
when it was originally implant,
I was probably still in
school. Um, like you know,
primary kind of school very early.
Um,
and then it took a long time to
build the mission and then, um,
it took 10 years for it to actually
from launch to get to it's comments.
So it had this massive journey in the
solar system to get to catch up with this
comment. So there's comment, um, call
it 67 peach therea mafia, Russell Manco.
Yeah.
Can't do that. I just like everybody
else. I just say Cherry Jerry. Oh, oh
yeah. You can say CG or does
nps a long name. Um, but uh,
it was traveling into the inner solar
system and the idea was that they launched
and had to decent gravitational slingshots
of different planets to catch up with
it. Again, enough speed cause you can't
just launch and go directly to a comment.
That's literally not how it works.
So we have to just catch up with it.
So it got onto an orbit eventually
is catch up with the comment,
came up on it from behind and then an
incident orbit around this thing that
we've never done this before. So you know,
start that just flew through the tail.
Um, but [inaudible] was just amazing.
It got to the comment and it,
it basically had to do a powered,
it couldn't get into orbit around
it cause the subject small,
it wasn't a real obit, but she's
with gravity, how it fly around it.
So these people doing this engineering
and all the science for this mission and
it just,
I just am amazed by how they did this,
but they didn't even know what this
object look like before we got there.
We had no idea of its
shape or its exact size.
We were expecting it to be sort of
round because we always kind of envisage
these objects to be sort of round.
Um,
and we got there and it turned
out to be like a rubber ducky.
Anything that says like it
caught everyone's attention
in the media quite a lot
because it literally has,
it looks like a rubber duck.
It's got this head and this body.
Um,
and I can't imagine how you figure out
how to fly around that thing without
bumping into it or whatever.
But we started to get images back from
this comment and they mapped 100% of the
surface of the comment cause they had
to pick somewhere to put a lambda down.
Right. Um, again, they,
they built this landed 20 years previous
and they didn't know what they were
going to be landing on.
Um,
do you call it candy philosophy
or the stuff you eat at the fair?
Kansy okay.
So we call it candy floss.
So one of the scientists
likened it to like,
they didn't know if they were getting my
landing on Candy floss or cotton candy
or cement. You know, they were like,
they had no idea for this concrete hard
or very soft and they were going to sink
in. So they had to build a lamb dish
after you just have to build a spacecraft
that's going to land on something
that you don't know what it is.
You have no idea what it is.
Exactly. It's, it's easy. Um, so,
you know, they launch, they
let the little lambs ago, um,
and the lender is called [inaudible]
and it just dropped to the comment.
But again,
remember there's not much gravity.
So the comment is not
attracting that thing to it.
The comments still rotating in space.
So they have chosen a landing
spot and they're like, yeah,
we want to add exactly here.
And sure enough,
it did initially land exactly where
they wanted it to go on this object.
That's like three by
five kilometers in size.
So it's not big and it all hurtling
towards the sun at the same time. Um,
unfortunately some stuff went wrong.
One of the harpoons that was meant to
fire when they landed in order to kind of
hold it onto the surface
and tether it there,
they already knew when they were
going through their procedures,
before they were going to release,
um, Phil, I that it wasn't working.
So they already thought, okay,
what can we do about this?
There's nothing we can do this, you
know, we have to just go for it.
Now we have to test it. So, you
know, they did their job right,
they got exactly where they wanted to,
but the land of bounced,
it bounced about
kilometer up into the air.
And other issue is that it could have
just completely left the comment because
it wasn't going to go back. It didn't
bounce quite high enough that it left.
So it went back down again. Um, and,
and it took a few hours and then it
landed again and had another balance.
So it's kind of hilarious.
It did the kind of three landings and
space and they were already planning to do
one. Unfortunately where it ended up, um,
was not the optimal position
for the solar panels.
So it was kind of under a slight cliff.
But we then learned that comments
have cliffs on them and you know,
overhanging sections. It's Kinda
crazy. Um, and but it did run,
it run its primary science sequence
when it got initially to the comment.
So we actually ended up sampling some
of the comic gasses and some of the dust
that was, um, from the
initial landing site.
And then it's in for the science later on.
So we still learned an awful lot.
So it kind of seems like a failure,
but it wasn't a failure all,
it's not at all this huge amount of
science done. Um, and, and we had, um,
when I was working at open university and,
and the UK,
we had one of the
instruments on the lander,
so we had a mass spectrometer that can
measure some of the components from,
from the gasses and there.
So we've got to learn what was,
what was on the comment.
That's right. And to your
surprise, you got, you got that,
you got samples from like three places
exactly. Work for this guy, Ray Arvidson,
great guy who, who would say all the
time, there's no bad data. Um, and so you,
you know,
just because you didn't get the exact
day that you plan to get doesn't mean you
didn't get some great stuff. We've
got the stuff from, you know,
because it was bouncing.
You got it.
We actually got multiple locations and
then we still have the old button that
was, you know, still orbiting around or
flying around the comment at the time. Um,
and doing its own work.
It was measuring lots of other experiments
and dangles over of the work and
measuring dust coming off and
collecting that and looking at the,
the plasma environment, how the,
how the comment reacts to the Sun,
which is very important because we didn't,
we don't really know how comments react
to the someone we know that they get
heated up and mixed girl
comes off. Um, but we,
we found out that actually every time
this comment 67 p went by the sun,
it loses about a meter of
material off its surface.
So it gets smaller and smaller because
those volatile isis and everything get
heated up and blown off the comment.
Then that dust that is sitting above it,
that's that kind of dehydrated
layer on top and it will comes off.
So you lose a huge amount of material.
And so it's a very active environment.
A comment is constantly changing and
you go, oh yeah, that these old objects.
And they, they preserved the very
old history of our solar system.
But actually if they come by the sun,
that changing all the time. And, um,
and we see that they have seasons.
We notice that the comment had
different seasons on it depending on,
on where you were on the comment and
where it was in relation to the sun.
So in that wow moves material around
the comic, we see movement of, you know,
like active processes like you
would see on a planet. It's crazy.
Yeah. That's amazing. I, I hadn't heard
that before. That's really cool. Um, uh,
so long as we're talking
about these space missions,
I just want to give a quick shout
out to the dawn mission, um,
which after 11 years of exploring,
uh, the asteroids, Vesta and Ceres is,
um, uh, is, is running out of maneuvering
fuels kind of middle of next month.
And so it's going to say goodbye to us,
but, uh, but just a little shout out to,
to dawn for a long end and
a honorable mission, um, uh,
increasing our understanding of the very
objects that we're talking about here.
Yeah. Um, so, uh, uh, uh, so, uh,
uh, uh, you were talking about, uh, the,
the, we, we talked about this earlier,
that there wasn't necessarily a sharp
distinction between these asteroids and
comets.
And so now that we've had these missions
to kind of look at asteroids close up
and look at comments close out,
we're kind of learning more about how
like there isn't asteroids and comets,
there's more like kind of attractors in,
in the space where there's,
there's things that we would constantly
call asteroids and things we would
constantly call comments,
but also a lot of things kind
of in between. Yeah. Um, so,
so what did we learn from these missions
that kind of helps us understand that
continuum a little better?
So I think we've,
we've learned that for me,
I think what I've learned is that
almost doesn't matter the, okay,
so we have objects that said at
either end of this continuum,
but if we want to study also the system,
it really doesn't matter which
ones we studied too much.
And the ones in the middle of probably
the most fascinating because they contain
the primitive materials. So the ones
that contain a lot of carbon, um,
and a lot of organic matter and the
ice is not, you know, is important.
But actually understanding the dust that
came from this beginning of the solar
system is great and the organic matter.
And so the next few missions that are
going to study these objects are both
going to asteroids. So
we've got, uh, Cyrus racks,
which is a NASA mission and there's a
Japanese mission could high booster too.
They did Hibu so one already
and that reflected some,
some sample and brought that
back. Um, and so we've had,
it didn't go completely successfully,
so they're taking another try.
I'm going to do it perfectly this time.
But these two missions have arrived
at their asteroids and they're both
basically primitive asteroids.
So they're almost, they're not,
they're not comment too,
like there's still asteroids,
but they have a lot of
primitive material in,
so we can try and understand these
kinds of beginnings of the solar system.
So they're both going to
be bringing samples back.
I've forgotten right now what
dates we're talking about,
but it's kind of within five years.
I think, or something like that.
We'll be returning materials.
So they've started their mapping phase
of these objects and they're going to be
looking where they're going to put
their lenders down and sampling.
But it's proper science fiction stuff.
I love it.
It's just fascinating
that they can do this.
We're going to the solar system and
like going to visit comets and asteroids
where they live in like bringing
stuff back there. Yeah, that's,
that's really amazing stuff. Um, so, uh,
so we talked a little about, uh, you know,
how they're going to kill us all and uh,
um, and uh, and what we would do about it.
So you talked about kind of like spray
painting in a asteroids and things like
that.
Um,
one of the techniques I had not heard
about before before reading your book was
a gravity tugs, which is
another interesting way of
diverting asteroids or, or,
or comments off their, uh, uh, path.
And it's nice because it works
with unconsolidated things as well.
I want to explain how gravity,
okay, so some of these objects,
even the asteroids, like I said,
the comments were not very
well consolidate and not
very well held together
because this is a scoop of
cloud kind of thing. Um,
and some of the asteroids on the
other hand, also a unconsolidated,
they might be made of rocky material,
but imagine just getting like a load of
big pebbles and cause kind of sticking
together and they sort of
held there because it was a
bit of gravity and there's
nothing really act on them in space that
would mean that they wouldn't just all
fall apart, but they, so they're
sort of loosely bound together. Um,
these objects are particularly
dangerous because they're hard to move.
If you want to hit them with something,
they'd probably just going to break up.
So we have to be very gentle with them.
If we know one of these objects
is heading towards us, um,
it's hard to know how they're going
to behave when they come through the
atmosphere.
Um,
so the gravity tractor thing is almost
just taking a spacecraft up and,
and using thrusters on one site
to sort of gently nudge and,
and basically it's the attraction between
that rubble pile and that spacecraft,
which isn't very much,
but if you've got enough advance warning,
you start doing that little playing
game and like nudging it back and forth
early enough,
then it will change it's orbit.
So essentially you just kind of want to
nudge it very gently and it's just that
gravitational attraction
between the two objects,
which obviously happens even if they're
small. Um, there is still something there.
So that would be very useful if it
were a rubble pile style asteroid.
I could work with other ones,
but I think that's probably the safest way
to move one of those maybe. Yeah. This,
yeah.
More research needed, right? Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. Um, and, and that's not,
that's something we haven't done
before. We actually have fired a, uh,
a bullet basically deep place
one. Right. Fired a bullet into,
into the side of a comment. We haven't
tried these other techniques at all.
Yeah. Deeds all kind of theoretical.
It a mission called deep impact,
which don't made a deep impact.
And that was confusing my bit,
cause my editor was like,
you've got a mission called him fat was
there's also Hollywood musical director
impacts. And I was like,
yeah, that's complicated. Um,
so I think I ended up taking
out all the references,
the movie version called Armageddon. Yes.
That would be good. Is it? Right. So yeah,
this mission actually, um,
basically pushed a boulder,
I fired a boulder into the side
of this comment to see wow.
Basically to see what would
happen because it's fun. Um,
but also to excavate a hole, um, so that
we could see inside the comment. Um,
it was kind of what I'm a little bit
wrong because they created so much dust
from this area,
you know,
impacts that the spacecraft couldn't see
anything cause it was just so much dust
everywhere. But like I actually, the
stardust mission and when it carried on,
when it's had to call it
samples and some of those back,
the status next mission had carried on.
Um, and it, it was managed to image, um,
that whole in that
crater that was created.
So we got to see processes
happening and again,
they saw changes happening over time in
that crater they created. So you see,
we've got this kind of active
comic thing again, um, which is,
which is really cool. So yes, it's
kind of one space mission did it.
And then we came back and had
another look, so. Right, right.
Um, so, uh,
we're just about 40 minutes
here and probably about
time to start kind of mixing
it, some audience questions. Um,
while we're kind of finding the first
victim and giving them the mic. Um,
one of the,
one of the major,
another major topic in your book was
about mining asteroids and comets. Um, uh,
so that the,
so they actually contain material that
would be useful to us on earth. Um,
it's not just organics but,
but also Nicole and uh, uh,
platinum and things like that.
Um,
you want to talk a little bit about kind
of mining techniques and kind of what
the state of the art there is.
Yeah.
So, of course, again, it sounds
like science fiction, it's like,
do we really need to mine in space? But
you know, those companies, a lot of them,
you know, a lot of stuff going on in
California where we want to, you know,
that's how she companies investing
in this. Trying to think, right?
Can we go my niece objects, we could
mind the moon. There's lots of um,
materials on the moon
that would be useful. Um,
but equally it might be easier to mine
asteroids, they can be easier to get to.
Um,
they don't have gravity,
so easy to get back from if we want to
launch her image it back and they contain
a lot of precious metals. So we all
love our smartphones and everything.
Computers, obviously we're
in Google, so we like, um,
all these materials that
require precious metals.
And if we're going to continue creating
new technologies in the future,
we need to know we've got a reliable
source of things like palladium, platinum,
all these things that are
used in and, um, technology.
We weren't be able to develop new
technologies if we don't know.
We've got a continued source of this
stuff and on earth things like platinum.
While that's expensive, because not much
of it, we find it very hard to mine.
It's very dispersed throughout the crust
of the earth and it's expensive to mine
and often not very good for
the environment to get out.
If we go to an asteroid,
well there's tons of it actually,
there's probably more platinum and some
single asteroids that we've ever mined
on the whole of the planet,
so we run into economical issues.
If we were to mine it and bring it back
to Earth where we'd crash the market and
obviously then it will probably be not
worth having done the whole mining thing.
Maybe we store it like we did with
diamonds and we really sit gradually and
control the market anyway.
I'm not an economist,
but there are issues to doing that.
It may cost trillions of dollars,
literally trillions of dollars to actually
launch the admissions and go and mine
these objects. But the chances
you could actually, you know,
there could be worth way more
than that. Um, so there is,
I guess if you have a lot of money and
you think it would be fun to go mine
asteroids, there is the potential
you could make a lot of money. Um,
of course we need reusable rockets because
it's just too expensive other ways we
need to so that obviously a lot of
companies are working on that right now.
Being able to cheapen,
getting stuff into space cause
it's just massively expensive.
But if we can find ways around this and
I think progress is definitely being
made at the moment.
Um,
we can get to space cheaply and
we can start to mine new subjects,
but we don't have to bring
all that stuff back to worth.
It could be useful in space.
And we want to go to Mars,
we want to venture out further into our
solar system. But we need, first of all,
fuel. It's very expensive
to bring fuel from Earth.
If we want to go out into
the solar system, fine,
we have enough fuel for a little while,
but then if we want to land somewhere
and go and visit somewhere else,
we need fuel. And if we launch it from
Earth, it's just very, very expensive.
The more fuel you take,
the more fuel you need to take that fuel.
And there's an exponential
relationship and it just gets crazy.
So if we can find the fuel in space
and sure enough we have water.
If we can split water needs,
get it into hydrogen oxygen,
we can create rocket fuel in space. So
again, it sounds like science fiction,
but we can then also use these objects
to make materials in space three d print.
What we require, instead of
taking a lot of tools from earth,
which we currently do,
if we go to the international space
station or stick everything with us and we
have to launch missions just
to, you know, resupply it.
What we wouldn't need to do that. We
could just actually go to three d print.
So they're actually tested three d printer
on the international space station.
And it sounds crazy, but yeah,
that is something we could do.
We just mind the asteroid,
get the materials we need and make the
tools we require in to space. So yeah,
it's, it's happening. It seems like,
I think the first steps in as an asteroid
mining are probably going to happen
within the next few decades.
The very tentative steps of like
getting their prospecting recently,
seeing what these objects contain and
then figuring out what kind of missions we
required to maybe tug them into an orbit
where they're sort of safe and they're
going to sit there quite happily so
that we can then launch a mission to,
to mind them in some way, whether we need
humans. It's unknown at the moment. Um,
this is why people talk about needing a
moon base for a lunar base for humans to
live and that they could then
mine from the moon kind of thing.
So it's a lot of unknowns at the moment,
but there's definitely progress
being made. And there are, you know,
there's like the u s has created laws
about now about mining in space and who
owns the, the materials they've
mine. So any US citizen,
theoretically if they mind something
in space, they can own that stuff,
which is kind of crazy.
And I don't know what the rest of the
world thinks about this at the moment.
I think Luxembourg are
following very similar laws.
I don't know if they've passed them
yet, but again, Luxembourg is tiny.
I don't know if you've been, but
there's not many people that live there.
So I'm not sure how many people are
in Luxembourg citizens. Um, but yeah,
is that fair? I kind of think,
well, okay, I'm not year since then.
I want to go and mind space,
but I wouldn't be allowed at the moment
to own the space that I, so yeah,
a lot of issues, um, and a lot of global
issues.
I think that we need to simply,
they're worth working out because there's
so much, there's so much potential,
so much wealth there. Uh, and,
and it's not just, you know,
wealth in terms of making you rich,
but wealth in terms of, as you said,
things like resources to make smartphones
and stuff like that that play it.
You know, I'd never, I'd never really
thought about this before, but uh,
asteroids like have all these resources
that we need and whole lot of fuel that
we can use to help further
explore the solar system.
Asteroids are basically
the convenience stores.
Thanks. Yeah, I kind of said like that the
gas station's right. Yeah, yeah, right.
Kinda pop there and get what
you need and then carry on.
Of course it's not as simple but right.
Yeah,
I kind of liked that idea that
it might happen in the future.
Okay. So I think we have an audience
question. Where did it ready to go?
Yeah, I was going to ask about
asteroid mining. Oh, okay. Okay, good.
I've ruined your question. I'm sorry
Brian. I actually have a question.
Have you ever seen the movie Melancholia?
No, I never heard of it. Check it out.
Basically the premise of that movie
is that a large planet sized bodies is
heading towards earth. Um, about the size
of Jupiter. It's huge. Oh my goodness.
Huge, ginormous. The thing is
that the scientific community, uh,
sees it well in advance,
like several years.
They're planning it and they're,
they're releasing all this information.
I don't want to give away
too much of the movie,
but the premise is that it basically
slingshots around the earth and they think
it's going to pass.
But the slight tug of gravity from the
earth is just enough where it reaches its
apex that it turns around
and comes straight back out.
So my question would be like,
um,
you're kind of doing the
theoretical science around
how we would deflect or move
something that is smaller than earth.
Is there any science or theoretical
physics and science going on about how we
would move something that could be much,
much larger?
Well, I think is almost 0%
chance of anything larger
than the earth hitting earth
because the solar system is
settled down now. So like I mean,
4.5 billion years ago, earth was
hit by a Mars size body, we think.
And that's why she formed the moon.
So it collided with the earth and we're
not sure what the details of that,
whether it was a direct impact or
as a kind of a side shot, a bit.
It probably almost certainly vaporize
the earth. And then from that we formed,
we formed our earth
again but also our moon.
So that's the kind of thing
that would happen. You know,
it would just be completely obliterated
if anything larger than Mazda to hit us.
But at this stage the solar
system settled and I mean,
I think it just couldn't happen,
but I mean you'd have to know.
I'm sure it makes for a good movie.
All the, have you seen this Mike,
by the way? This is really
cool. You just toss it around.
I did wonder what it was
when it was hot up here.
Yeah.
Uh,
so I was fascinated to hear about
the inner and outer asteroid belt.
Um, and it sounds like they're
materially different. So,
I mean the outer one has a bit more ice
would maybe you'd expect is farther from
the sun,
but uh,
other than that or these different
populations and so what segregates them?
So it's just probably more like
based on density. Um, so the,
the inner objects are denser and
formed under hotter conditions,
so they're more consolidated,
their rocky then metally the
ones on that outer edge, uh,
probably they're probably form what the
comment is falling and when knocked into
there. So they are a lot less than
say, probably have a lot of poor space.
So actually when we got to the
risotto comment, I'm 67 P we,
we weren't able to measure its density.
Um,
which is really cool because although
it's made of rock and it's made of ice,
it's actually has a really
low density, um, because it's,
it's got lots of holes in it,
so they're not,
because it's not like gaping big holes
in the side of it and like cavities,
but it's very porous. Every
fine scale, but very poorest.
Like it's got a lot of gaps in it. So
it's just not very well pushed together.
Whereas the objects on the inner
asteroid belt, a very kind of, no,
probably no ball space whatsoever.
Um, so that basically controls it.
So these as you move on out,
you've just probably got a transition
gradually from the inner to outer.
Gotcha. Thank you. Okay.
In College I did something,
uh,
where we had,
um,
we had designed these transmitters
to put on near Earth objects. Um,
that there was a lot of concern that
the smaller objects that were harder to
detect,
um,
could be the thing that does us in instead
of the larger objects that are easier
to detect. Yeah. Um, and it was just a,
is a design class.
We didn't actually deploy it,
but is there any like movement and trying
to do anything to look at near Earth
objects. Okay. So
yeah, we are currently tracking, uh,
basically all the narrow objects
that we can possibly see. Um,
the ones that are caught
sort of a normal orbits.
I say those ones because there could
be some random objects that are at the
moment far out that are going
to become near Earth objects.
But we don't know they're coming
here because they're very small. But,
so those are kind of the unknown.
The unknown. Unknown's I guess. Um,
but the ones that we can see and we
are tracing the orbits of all the time,
so we're constantly updating where we
think they're going and how that spinning
because it's very important to
understand how they heat it up.
I said earlier about deflect to them.
If he paint one side a different color,
it will spin differently.
Well, there's two effects that
happen in space. Your pen,
your cops get effects and that and they,
that determines how these things spin
and how it affects that all bit basically
as they heated up by the sun.
So it's,
we sort of know most of
them are going to hit us,
but we need to just define
those two phenomena very
clearly and then we can know
exactly where they're going to go.
So some of these objects are
on sort of a hazardous less,
but we just need to better define where
they're going and then they can be
removed from that list.
But yeah,
when we're talking about
the size of these things,
it's funny because even if it was just
a couple of hundred meters across,
it could still cause a lot of damage
depending on what it was made of.
If it's a pure piece of
metal, yeah, sure enough it's,
it's going to probably get through the
atmosphere quite easily and wherever that
hits okay.
It might not cause global devastation
like we saw with the dinosaurs being
killed off,
but you know,
it could cause quite a lot of issues
and we've had impacts in the past,
which haven't been massive, but
they can create things like, yeah,
nuclear winters essentially,
you can have it as a near like a,
when you get a massive volcanic eruption,
like it's the same kind of thing.
You can change the climate of the
planet for a considerable time.
And I would suggest that humans are
fairly kind of, um, a vulnerable species.
We want clean water, we require
movement around the planet quite a lot.
And I think if anything like
that happened, we could be
quite vulnerable species.
So, even if it was a smallish impacts, um,
it could just cause quite a lot of issues.
Obviously the larger impacts,
if we're talking kilometer
sized bodies are larger,
they're going to be a bigger problem. So
understanding those kinds of small ones,
there's still quite large
is really important area,
kind of 400 meters across and so
is they're pretty dangerous. Um,
and they're hard to see.
So we need to understand those,
especially if they're dog, if they're
proper lake, dark carbonaceous asteroids,
they're very hard to see because
they don't give off much light.
So that's what astronomers rely on,
these things giving off light and
that's why comments are easier to see.
They shine. Whereas asteroids can be a
bit sneaky. So we have to be careful.
I have a question about the interstellar
dust stuff gets collected. Um,
it might be outside the
scope of this conversation,
but I was wondering if it
gives us any kind of, um,
understanding of the original big
bang and maybe supporting the,
the theory of the Big Bang.
Um,
or is it really more like stuff that's
4.6 million years old and it's very
localized dust.
So I'm going to have to say,
I don't know to what some of the actually,
cause I've not kept up with that
interstellar stuff very well,
but I know that it's basically allow
us to look into our local galaxy.
Um, and I don't exactly know
when that dust was formed. Um,
but what they've been able
to do is actually measure,
like the eyes are tapes of the
elements of that material. Um,
and that allows us to understand
a lot about our local environment,
like what our solar system
formed from and have a seat.
We expect that different galaxies are
going to be different compositions, um,
because they formed at
different times maybe,
I mean the were still don't
really understand all of that.
So because we haven't able
to sample it or, you know,
look at it very clearly because
these things are so far away.
So it's kind of understanding a little
bit further back in our history, um,
what is in there. But yeah, I'd
have to say I'm not too sure. Yeah.
So recently there was big news about this,
uh,
asteroid from outside the solar
system that blitzed through. Oh,
I'm so glad you mentioned this. I haven't
mentioned it yet, so yeah. Yeah. Okay,
great. Um, is that something that uh,
was a one in a hundred year
event or was that a question of
our sensors are getting better and
we can expect to see more of them?
The more we play the latter. So we think,
so I'll just backtrack a little bit.
Say this, I'm objects that
came through our solar system.
We actually think now it
was probably a comment,
but we're not a hundred percent sure.
We weren't able to measure it very well
cause we didn't know it was coming,
but so it wasn't on the normal or bear
that all the other comments and asteroids
and planets are on. It just literally
came zipping through our solar system.
It was so fast that it didn't even get
caught into the gravity of our sun.
It just zip by and it came from some
other star system. We have no idea where.
And it's probably been some
like interstellar traveler
for forever. Who knows?
When it formed, it came
from very far away. Um,
so it's been going for at least billions
of years. Um, and it just zipped through.
So we don't know a lot about it. We just
know that it's, I think it's called Moo.
Is it called Miramar? Like I think
it's Hawaiian for Muah. Muah. I think.
Um, and I think it's Hawaiian
for something like a distant
traveler or something
like this. Um, I probably pronounced
it wrong. I didn't know Hawaiian. Um,
but basically we,
if we knew one of these was coming,
we could launch a mission again to
go and sample it because this will be
fascinating. We'd learn about that
star system that it came from,
which could be completely different to
what we're seeing here. Probably would be,
um, it could be the same, who knows,
but we know it came from somewhere else
and we just haven't seen one of these
before.
I think probably other objects like
that have gone through the solar system,
but we haven't spotted them.
They get very fast.
I think it was just chance
that it was seen as well. Um,
but it is fascinating and I would love
to have some sample of that comment.
There would be so cool to analyze.
But um, yeah, I'm hoping, you know,
in the future as we get better at
seeing these things coming again,
it wasn't very big.
It was also really weirdly shaped.
It was like a cigar shape and really
long and kind of like, you know,
maybe it's some alien spaceship,
who knows.
Basically you're saying we're
being visited by cigars.
Yeah,
it would be so happy. Um, uh, so, uh, we
just have a couple minutes left and I,
I wanted to ask you,
um,
if a European space agency or NASA or
somebody came to you and said, hey,
we'd like you to be the
principal investigator,
that is the top science person
for the next space mission,
it's going to go and maybe
explore one of these objects.
What would you want it to be?
What would you do it?
What would you do with that mission?
Oh, I wouldn't be able to cheese. I mean,
so at the moment we've got these missions,
Osiris Rex, I'll give you two, just one.
So I,
I would want to go and explore the
cope about better get samples of it.
I'd want to explore more of the
comments but equally some of them really
exciting scientific things happening
right now and sell it to us and you've
opened up,
this isn't comets and asteroids but this
is potentially finding a life in our
solar system.
Um,
these are moons of Jupiter and Saturn and
they have liquid oceans beneath an icy
crust and there's a really high
potential that they could have life.
Probably not intelligent life, but there
could be life then for me at the moment.
I'm just fascinated by that and I,
we are going to one it
again to your right per,
so hopefully my wife was
working in Europe only. Okay.
So that's going to be seen and
we will hopefully go there.
The Europa Clipper mission, um, Enceladus,
unfortunately we found the Ansel or just
had this liquidation as after they'd
already planned the sessions she wrote.
But,
but it might actually be a better
place to look for life. It might,
it doesn't have quite the same horrible
radiation environment that you ripped
pat.
So I fuck on shoes and actually cotton
choose Pluto is also fascinating.
It would, we've flown by it. We've learned
a lot by just flying by it, but it's an,
it's a copa object.
It's basically a large comment and um,
but there's probably other
really fascinating objects
in the Kuiper belt that we
need to look at.
So we just haven't explored it enough.
We need and it's just too far away. So
yeah, I need to kind of speed up, time,
time travel and then come back and get
some samples. But yeah, I didn't know.
It's, it's wonderful to have so many
good choices. Yeah, that's true.
Um, doctor Starkey thi this has been a
terrific conversation. Thank you so much.
Um, keep having the book.
Absolutely. Our pleasure. Uh,
the book is catching stardust,
comets,
asteroids in the birth of the solar
system and all this stuff we talked about
and so much more as in it. I
encourage you to read it. Um,
please join me in thanking
our guest today, Dr Natalie's.